- Yeah, I mean I'm just a regular
guy that's never met a puppy.
I don't know why people thinks that weird.
(electric guitar music)
- I'm here to meet some pup-pups.
- I feel like I'm gonna just turn
into a child when I see them.
- Since I haven't had a dog I feel
like something's missing in my life.
- I am concerned that I may
have a puppy bite my mustache.
- I'm excited to meet any puppy right now.
- Come here, hey.
(upbeat music)
- These puppies are total divas right now.
They just don't want to play with me.
(laughter)
- I protect them.
(puppy whining)
- He didn't bite my mustache.
- Well, I mean, I think everything's
cuter when it's a baby, right?
- Whoah, this dude is so tiny.
- Uh-oh, he's got a piece
of bark or something.
- Want a treat?
- I'm in love with this dog.
- He's just so freaking cute.
Oh, he's running away.
- Yeah, he's gotta go.
He's using it.
- What's the matter?
You're so excited.
- How's it going?
Look at you, you're so happy.
- Love this dog.
It's a great dog.
- Is that what you want?
How about you?
- Ahhhhhh.
I'm missing one.
- Oh (laughs) Bear's got it now.
- I kind of bonded with these dogs.
I don't now, they're just,
they're just so full of life.
- It makes me want to order one right now.
- It's uh, it's like
being with an old friend.
- I believe a pup-pup
will choose me some day.
And when the call is
made, I will answer it.
- Uh, my name is uh, like Sean.
Puppies are not a big deal.
(fake crying)
I'm so happy.
I guess someone could love this, you know.
Who's the baby.
(making puppy yelps)
- And that is all.